Tellurium is, is quite a nice element here.
I shall pick it up carefully.
Tellurium.
You’ve never had anything to do with this?
Nothing to do with it in my life. So this
is a new one for me. This is
tellurium powder. So let’s see what’s
inside the vial. So as we open it and
tap out the glass vial. This one is going
to be stubborn.
This bell shape here is a sample of tellurium.
The reason…shall I hold it
for you? … so, a sample of tellurium. I’m
slightly cagey about touching
this because as I think I explained with selenium
that, if you ingest tellurium into
the body it can get into your sweat and make
you smell enough to really
drive people mad. And these crystals like
this one can be cut up and
mounted into a piece of apparatus like this.
So a chemist won’t deal with all the elements
on the periodic table in his
career normally.
No, no, very few chemists will deal with more
than perhaps a
handful of different elements. So this is
the tellurium and this is, again,
this is very high standard material. 3 grams
of the tellurium material and
you can see it’s a very dark powder at the
bottom of the vial.
It was used in this piece of apparatus to
shine in an infrared laser that’s
like a heat ray at one frequency and it came
out as twice the frequency.
So you can use it to change the effect of
the lasers. Unfortunately the
guy doing it didn’t make a very good job
of it and you can see he’s
completely burnt the surface of this piece
of tellurium. So the main use
of tellurium is as components like this for
laser optics and it’s not widely
used in the chemical industry or similar areas.